hi everyone this is the second part in
the series of videos looking at stuff
sparring if you've not seen the first
video I recommend going watching that
before seeing this I'll post links in
the description below this video will
focus on sparring with the foamer stuff
which is padded but also heaviest out of
all three okay so let's go through this
video I'm on the left wearing black
shoes Rogers on the right wearing white
shoes I'm gonna let this video play out
on court then we'll go through it up
there and break it down in slow motion
[Music]
okay so this is the first part I want to
look at I go for a one-handed strike to
the head and large moves out the way now
you can see I anticipate contact as the
stuff stops momentarily instead of
following through this can happen when
you try and control the amount of power
you put into a strike as we often
practice with steel swords it can
sometimes build this habit as there's a
higher chance of injury therefore we try
and exercise more control it's just
something to be mindful of in this next
part go for the same strike and make
contact it's a bit unclear whether it
Rogers head or hand or if you manage to
block it with his stuff defense why
stepping back and getting out of the way
would be my preferred option as this
will give a better opportunity to
counter so here ROG counters my thrust
with a one-handed strike to my shoulder
similar to what I did earlier he
controls his stuff so the impact wasn't
that much with assault this would be a
sufficient amount of power overdue to
have been Joe and being blunt
it relies more on heavier impact here
Roger traverses as Joanne goes for a
high thrust however I count away the
strike to his head it's a fairly
standard strike which is practiced
regularly and works pretty much in the
same way with a 200 sword so we have
another 100 strike this time coming from
below go for Rogers head but it looks
like I catch him on the hand with that
type of grip I'd personally choose to
drop under and raise the tip of the jaw
to defend that would then give a good
position to attempt to counter again I
go for the same 100 strike and this time
miss however unlike at the start a
follow through which gives me the
opportunity to continue the attack so
looking at in slow motion I try to go
for Rogers hand though I very slightly
out reach he tries to not my job the way
of misses I let my jaw flow through and
try and attack his exposed side ROG
moves back out the way and I let the
movement of the job continue and turned
it into a thrust as he moves back he
goes for a strike however neither the
strike whole thrusting to make a
significant contact
so in this clip Raj comes for a thrust
and I count it with a strike to his head
although it might not be apparent foam
really slows down their hand exchange
and turnover of the joke
so I rarely use these strikes with foam
in this exchange I open up and try and
bait Raj to attack which he does with a
high thrust and I count up with a thrust
it's hard to make out but after watching
it back in slow motion I think I might
have caught him on the other side that's
out shot if you can see the job ends
which suggests the contact was made
say hey Raj appears to be going for my
arms then I counter with a strike to his
head one major difference compared with
wood is that form jobs are very bouncy
so it won't react the same way if you
used to training wood any contact seems
to recoil or unexpected in this last
part Raj goes through a strike and I
counter with a thrust neither lunge
however I follow up with the thrust at
those so breaking it down in slow motion
Raj goes from a strike to my hand and I
attempt to parry no contacts made and I
draw it back to thrust notice that I
thrust on the spot and overreach and I'm
nowhere near making contact with this
second thruster take a step forward
bringing her back for up to getting this
timing right in closing the distance
enable me to make contacts and knocking
Raj backwards also as a side note notice
when Raj goes for the strike his job
ends round mine this significantly
changes the feel of the job compared to
wood so going back to the thrust this
idea of moving your body as a unit is
generally what we're trying to achieve
in Aikido in summary the foam Jo has a
reasonable weight given its material and
with the padding there's no real need
for excessive protection this means it's
possible to experiment more and try
things out not being said complacency
can kick in this getting here isn't an
issue also the other downside is the
handling is a bit cumbersome due to
having a soft surface and too much flex
although the foam stuff handles very
differently to standing wooden Joe it's
still good to use if someone's new
aspiring for those that do Aikido I'm
sure you can see plenty in there however
also do a video at the end of this
series summarized in the Aikido used for
our anyway I hope you found this
interesting the next one will be looking
out will be sparring with plastic jaws
until then take care